sometimes Wars fun new trailer out for
civil war this is not a movie I've
actually weighed in on in videos but i
don't know why after this point but i'm
gonna weigh in on this one and yeah I
like it I like it a lot azza most of the
first road which was much more just sort
of action oriented and give us a lot of
whiz-bang who this one actually kind of
lays out the plot a bit more that's
nothing that I wasn't expecting and
everything seems to make sense but there
were little glimpses of stuff that
really intrigued the heck out of me some
examples would be vision brought to his
knees by Scarlet Witch I think this was
somebody that actually really needed to
do for the geeks like me who are as soon
as it was announced that vision was
actually going to be in this it was like
well guys got an infinity stone in his
head once he picks aside isn't it kind
of over no we've got someone who can
actually stand up to this guy and I
would not have necessarily called it at
scarlet witch but yeah Udo I really like
what we're seeing a black panther I'm
really excited to see how he's gonna
work he looks jacked to I mean we watch
him catch up to a motorcycle on foot
I'll be curious to see how much of that
is going to be like the suit
enhancements that are giving him that or
if they're also going to have sort of
the the herbal cocktail that he that he
takes in the comics or can i maybe that
suit goes to a performance-enhancing
drugs for the movies but i don't know i
would kind of like to see them do both
right now i'm giving 5050 odds on
whether or not rody is dead or not i can
make an argument either way on the one
hand that doesn't seem like the kind of
thing you want to give away in a trailer
on the other hand they've never really
figured out what to do with him as a
character ever since he got the war
machine suit and well this would kind of
solve that problem in addition to the
fact that i really think somebody needs
to die in this movie and stay dead
that's kind of the big thing because
Marvel has a tendency to kill oh wait
they're still alive and killing rody
would also really make it deeply
personal for Tony because this this can
probably start as more of an ideological
split between Tony and cap but because
these two guys are friends if its own
ideological then ultimately they would
have to realize okay this is getting out
of control we got to bring this back in
but if you make it personal and for cap
that is because of Bucky and we make it
personal for iron man because of roadie
well then that allows for that
escalation because they're too
personally invested to see how out of
control this is all getting you don't
necessarily have to kill rody to have it
still go that direction for Tony and for
iron man but you know it it would that
would do the trick certainly tons of
other little things ant-man riding on a
narrow I mean how could they not give us
that and of course the elephant the room
the one that everyone's talking about
Spidey if I am being completely honest I
kind of wish he was left out of the
marketing I think that everyone was
gonna see this movie anyway they did not
need to put him in there to get people
to see it I think it would have been
better if he was just they just put him
in there and he wasn't part of the
marketing at all obviously that's not
what happened and that being said this
revealed pretty darn awesome the soups
nice is really colorful it pops I like
what they're doing with the eyes and I
think and they're sort of allowing for a
certain degree of expression you look
really close and there seems to be
actually some kind of rigid lines in the
thing that it's like I think there's
probably only three settings of like I'm
going wider or more narrow with the eyes
probably a function of the mask of some
kind but you know what that alone gives
it more animation than spider-man's mask
generally haves and that's kind of been
a one of the big problems with the
spider-man designs in all the spider-man
movies really is how unexpressed avast
is and they found a way around that so
awesome and now that we have seen him I
hope we don't see any more of him in any
more of the trailers or any of the
marketing I just you've established for
people who aren't like me and are
following this thing and maybe are more
casual you you're now letting them know
hey spider-man's in this to everybody
knows now don't wreck anymore and you
know it's funny I had to actually think
about it to myself why did I like this
reveal of spider-man when I didn't like
the similar reveal of Wonder Woman of
the Batman V Superman trailer and a lot
of that just has to do
what I've kind of extrapolated about the
circumstances that we are seeing because
the vibe that I get from this scene
where spider-man gets revealed is that
this is probably around the middle of
the movie because I mean you've got Tony
still cracking wise you know he calls
for spider-man by going underoos and
that the whole vibe of the thing to me
is more things are building but this is
not the climax Tony would this is gonna
get so heavy and so personal and so you
know down and dirty Tony's not gonna be
crackin wise come to climax of this
thing so I really get the feeling that
what we saw there is is only in about
the middle of the film everything that
we see in the Wonder Woman reveal in the
Batman V Superman trailer that felt like
we were watching the final climactic
fight of the movie and that's why that
annoy me now ultimately if it turns out
that that is not the case in Batman V
Superman and that reveal of Wonder Woman
only happens in midway through the movie
I will I guess retro actively apologize
and because then I would just have
gotten angry at that movie because of a
misinterpretation on my part but again
I'm just going by the vibe I'm getting
in the Batman V Superman that felt like
they were showing us the final
confrontation and spoiling stuff from
that and I never got that feel from this
trailer we see lots of stuff but I don't
feel like this thing is laying it all
out there I feel like there's still a
ton we haven't seen and there is a ton
we haven't seen this characters we still
haven't seen we only get the quickest
glimpse of crossbows we still haven't
seen Baron Zemo we haven't seen Martin
Freeman whoever he's playing so I feel
like Civil War still has a lot of
bullets left in the chamber Batman V
Superman by the time all the trailers
came out I felt like well I felt like
I've seen the whole movie and when I
eventually actually do see it maybe that
will not turn out to be the case and
that will be a plus a surprise if so but
it feels like that has shown me all its
tricks already civil war does not feel
like it showed me all its tricks but the
tricks it has shown me they make me
pretty darn excited but even though all
the talk has been about Spidey I have to
say unequivocably favorite moment in the
whole trailer Chris Evans as cap
delivering that line I could do this all
day you know I've called out the
original Captain America for being
overweight and I do feel it is but
calling
to that to something he said when he was
still a scrawny little bugger getting
pushed around in an alley that that's a
thing of beauty so what was your
favorite moment out of the civil war
trailer or did you hate it whatever your
thoughts were put something down in the
comments and let's talk about it please
don't forget to Like subscribe follow me
on twitter at council of geeks check out
the council of geeks podcast on itunes
and stitcher you can email me at council
of geeks @ gmail.com and until next time
this council is adjourned